Hey YouTubers it's Charlie, so this is going to be my
preview of all the big TV shows that are coming
this summer there's actually quite a few
that are premiering I might not do videos
for all them on a weekly basis but always
be doing some of the premiers a lot of you've
also been asking me about shows that are on
break I will be doing weekly bonus videos
for pretty much everything that I normally
do videos for that means the flash game of
thrones all that stuff while it's on break so
don't worry about that but these are all new
shows that are starting this summer so big
stuff first Jonathan Strange and Mr. Norrell
it might not be something that you guys have
heard of before some you may have read the
book you can think of it as a grown-up version
of Harry Potter like a game of fairy thrones
there are actually couple similarities the
game of thrones it's a revisionist history
tell like in the same way Harry Potter is
your whereby magic exists in the real world
where this series picks up it's been gone
for 300 years these two people have to bring
it back if you member during game of thrones
season one year dragons work on nobody believed
in magic but it was said to have existed in
the past come to the end of that season you
know you find dragons come back into the world
and we get to see some magic in season two
for Melisandre this is a British drama so
the tone is little bit different game of thrones
is an American series produced internationally
so it it feels much more like an HBO American
series this is a BBC series if you've never
watched British drama before it just it plays
a little bit differently but is still a lot
of fun there seven episodes total and they're
basically doing the entire story from the
book that Susanna Clarke wrote they haven't
said whether or not they're doing is season
two but Susanna Clark is working on a sequel
novel she started in 2004 it's been about
10 years it took her about 10 years to write
the first novel though even if she doesn't
finish with that second but they should have
enough material to do a season to it's already
started airing in the UK so was probably can
happen is is I'll probably wait till it premieres
in the US to do my episode one video what
I'll probably do is an episode of the beginning
of the season and then I'll do a review of
the entire season when it's all over next
up is Doctor Who series 9 that's going to be
at the end of August just like last year that
will put it on August 22 for episode one you
never watched Dr. Who before this is a good
time to jump on Everone was asked questions
about Dr. Who because there's such a long
history I try to make my Dr. Who videos assuming
the you you you you have a watch like the
entire history of Doctor Who so don't worry Peter
Capaldi was a great doctor so I'm looking
forward to him coming back Jenna Coleman is
coming back is the companion and Missy or
the master how ever you want to think about her is
going to be big character,  way bigger than
she was last season next show after that is
Fear The Walking Dead that's going to premier
around the same time but they haven't confirmed
an official date yet just as they do every
year they will be bringing a whole bunch of
new footage too, can't that's the first week
in July that's the good thing they've been
pretty vague about when that shows going to
start but it's six episodes just like they
did for walking dead season one what happened
is is whenever The Walking Dead first aired
a couple years ago they did six episodes for
season one I guess just to see how we do and
that was season two rolled around they got
a full season so they'll probably do that
with fear The Walking Dead the spinoff show
is a prequel it picks up when Rick is in his,
like right around the time of the outbreak
they did to the timeline of the show would
catch up with the main show eventually so
maybe like season two or season three of fear
The Walking Dead the run concurrently with
the probably going to do is air all the episodes
of fear The Walking Dead in the lead up to
the season six premiere the main show the
main show always premieres the second week
in October so you just doing reverse math
they could either start fear The Walking Dead
at the end of August or the beginning of September
the problem with that is that they said it
was started airing at the end of the summer
in September is not the summer so I have to
wait till they do that big, can't handle the
beginning of July to announce the official
day don't worry though be a whole bunch of
trailer footage the probably screen the first
episode there so I'll do nonsporting reviews
of all at stuff but Robert Kirkman is much
more involved with the spinoff show that he
is with the main show your big fan the comics
and Robert Kirkman you will enjoy the spinoff
show moving under the smaller stuff so Star
Wars Rebels is going to air their first episode
June 20 that's called the siege of withal
the screen for the first time back in April
it is Star Wars celebration but most you will
be singing for the first time the regular
series though will pick up in October just
like did last year Freddy Prince Junior is
is is really funny when he talks about the
series he did say that it would have double
the episodes of season one that's not confirmed
that with put it somewhere between like 20 or 22
episodes the guardians of the galaxy cartoon
that I just posted the trailer for is supposed
air the end of the summer there's no official
date so I'm expecting August the because the
laser so common in the world of animation
I wouldn't be surprised if it pushed the premier
to September there's a whole bunch of the
stuff that I will be making content for on
Twitter and Facebook there there wasteland
description but here's a rundown of like all
the other stuff Annable season three starts
on June 4 and the their billing it is like
the bride of Hannah bowl with Joanne Anderson
it looks spectacular and terrifying I don't
think of be doing a lot of videos for but
I I will be in these be doing stuff on Facebook
and twitter that a little bit after that on
June 12 the people that made Stargate Atlantis
have a new show called dark matter premiering
on sci-fi right now it's the only space operated
there is so I would recommend you check it
out true detectives season two starts on June
21 at HBO of course always do a video for
the premier the only thing that worries me
about this season is that they took a lot
of the mythology out of the show like a lot
of the really trippy stuff that made season
one awesome the rock also does have a new
show on HBO is called bollards it's basically
like entourage first sportspeople not planning
on doing videos for Bremen to check it out
at the end of June team will season five starts
and scream the scream series is based on the
films if you guys watched Aeros sin as part
of that series that's why she's not on Aero
I'm not planning on doing team will videos
but I will watch because this will probably be the
last season of Teen Wolf. Penny Dreadful is
on Showtime it's still in the middle that's
run its it's a Sunday night show I recommend
you check it out I don't know that on the
be doing videos for but it's spectacular and
everybody is really excited about the new
X-Files miniseries are doing early next year
David Duchovny Gillian Anderson right now
David the company has a series called Aquarius
you can stream all the episodes for free on
NBC.com think of it is like an X-Files miniseries
built around the ministry of Charles Manson
is super dark it just so happens that Renly
Baratheon from game of thrones is playing Charles
Manson so that she gets me excited least so
That's just a quick rundown of some of
the big stuff is happening in the next couple
months I you and I will do preview videos
whenever seasons get ready to start pseudoword
because, con is happening so early this year
also to do preview videos for comic con in
a couple weeks to so be sure to subscribe
to get that I have a pretty good idea of the
type of supplement to be doing their there
is a rumor that Marvel's not to go but they
haven't confirmed that yet though the pry
waits for the last minute to say yes or no
this year's going to be really huge for all
the DC TV shows in the Warner Bros. DC movies
they will be bringing a ship ton of footage
is going to be awesome if is anything specific
that you guys want to request that I didn't
mention just let me know in the comments is
this something that you guys really walk but
I I don't have time to do like full weekly
videos for all least try to do something on
Facebook I don't have anybody helping me yet
like I still do all the stuff by myself but
hopefully by the fall I will have like a I
hope her son will be will be easier for me
to do stuff if you confused about the bonus
video schedule the days the videos would normally
post will be the days that bonus videos typically
post like the flashers on Tuesdays that's
usually my videos post that's the day the
bonus videos for that'll post usually every
morning I'll post on twitter Facebook that
the video schedule for the day so if you ever
curious you just checked on her Facebook so
don't forget about new game of thrones tomorrow
I'll be posting a bonus video and then my
episode video did just like normal way he
is with us at the post you can click here
for last week's episode and you can click
here to learn all about Maester Aemon thank
you so much for watching everybody, let's
high five and I'll see you tomorrow.